Speaker 1: OK, so I'm going to be up front with
everybody, there is a bunch of Trump stuff to
catch up on in today's show. I don't even want
to wait to get into it because this past weekend
has confirmed beyond any doubt Trump is in for
twenty, twenty two. And if he succeeds at getting
his friends elected, Trump is in for 2024. This
weekend, Donald Trump gave a major public speech
at a Republican event and published a recorded
video message in which he says some completely
outrageous things which we are going to get to.
And the complete totality of the Republican base
is deferring to Donald Trump. Now, I know Mitt
Romney isn't OK. Mitt Romney is not. Liz Cheney
is not deferring to Trump. Fine. Most Republicans
are. And importantly, most Republican voters are
still with the guy. And it is very quickly taking
an outrageous turn. Now, I also have to tell you,
not only did the things Donald Trump said
raise red flags politically, as you will see,
he was as incoherent and as visibly confused
as ever during this speech that he gave. And
it's not, oh, Joe Biden has a stutter, but he's
thinking clearly. This is Trump has no stutter,
but he seems completely confused by the things
he's saying and what's going on around him.
So this speech was at the North Carolina
Republican Party Saturday event. Here's
one example of the incoherence. Trump talking
about suspended removals and removable removals
and looking confused and sweating
profusely. And it's all horrible.
Speaker 2: Biden has halted while
construction suspended removals
and even removable removals of just horrible.
Speaker 1: If Biden spoke like that once, it would
be 48 hours on Fox News when Joe Biden stutters
once, even though we know he has a stutter.
Sean Hannity brings in doctors or people
that he just asks medical questions to,
even if they're not doctors. OK, so then the
substance of sorts, and it's still pretty
weak as far as substance goes. Trump opening the
speech by claiming a huge success on the pandemic,
which has been managed for the last five
months by the Joe Biden administration.
Trump talking as if he's still in power.
Speaker 2: We've done an incredible job and
most importantly, with the vaccine coming up with
it. But we've done an incredible job and so many
things have happened. And we built the economy not
once. We built it twice. Think of it because we've
built it. We had the highest stock market ever,
the best job numbers. And then we had to regroup.
We had to do a lot of things. We bought we we
became the ventilator factory of the world. We
were making them for everybody. And we had and
our cupboards were bare, the federal coverage
were bare and the state governments were bare.
Speaker 1: Donald Trump maybe doesn't understand
verb tense as well as some of us, but he seems to
be talking like he's still in charge. And lots of
the Kuhnen people believe that indeed he is still
in charge. And this just reinforces that thinking.
By the way, this phrasing that Trump uses, we did
an incredible job of coming up with the vaccine
that really takes a special kind of narcissism
and delusion. We did a great job coming up with
a vaccine now on pandemic stuff, Trump is
still calling the 1918 flu, the 1917 flu.
I don't know why. Remember, we interviewed a flu
historian on the show and historian and said,
is there any reason you could call the 1918 flu,
the 17 flu? He said, no, there just is no reason
for that. Here's Trump doing it again.
Speaker 2: You would have had a 1917
Spanish flu. No, they lost, they say, up to
100 million people. You would have had those.
Speaker 1: I guess it's a case of if
you accidentally say it wrong once,
if you're a narcissist, you just stick with it for
years because you can't admit that you were ever
wrong about anything. Then Trump gets into the
current investigations of him and see if you can
even remotely understand what he's saying here.
Speaker 2: The radical left prosecutors go after
Trump, just give it a shot. They say give it a
shot. They failed in Washington. They failed all
over the place between the impeachment hawks.
No. One, impeachment hawks. No to all of these
investigations are we failed. Let's send it to
the radical left prosecutors in New York. Maybe
they can have more luck. They'll never stop until
November of twenty twenty four. They won't stop.
Speaker 1: I guess the take away is the point
is it's all a hoax. Trump being very edgy.
They're right, guys. Impressive stuff. Trump
then keeps talking about these investigations
and he simply doesn't sound well. It seems to
be getting to him in some kind of deep way.
Speaker 2: What did he do? Well, we
don't know, but we'll figure it out.
Washington Post reported the other day they've
gotten millions of pages of documents. Well, when
did he do a deal or did he do another deal? Did
they go through every day or every deal I've ever
done? Millions and millions of pages. If there's
a common mistake, if there's a misspelling,
it's problems. You know what? It's a disgrace
to our country. It's prosecutorial misconduct.
They're in search of a crime, it's a fishing
expedition, and the Supreme Court of the
United States should not have allowed it to
happen, shouldn't have allowed it. And they
mention it can't be a fishing expedition. This
is the ultimate fishing expedition. It's been
a five year long witch hunt, hoax
after hoax, Russia, Russia, Russia.
Speaker 1: Trump really has a long list of
things that the Supreme Court should do.
I don't know if you've noticed they should
stop the investigations into Trump. They should
have given Trump the 2020 election. He's very
disappointed in. What's interesting about this is
if your whole life, the way things have worked
is when I give somebody a job, they do me favors.
He probably doesn't understand. How could it
be that a Supreme Court with three justices on
it that he picked isn't doing exactly what he
wants him to do? That's different than the way
Donald Trump's career has gone so far. And
then this next clip really takes some gall.
After obstructing an investigation into himself
and trying to steal the election and inciting
an insurrection, Trump has the audacity
to say he is trying to save democracy.
Speaker 2: No, I am not the one trying to
undermine American democracy. I'm the one
that's trying to save it. Please remember that.
Speaker 1: The opposite is true, of course,
Donald Trump, one of the biggest threats
to American democracy as we know it.
So there it is. I mean, a completely vapid
and low energy speech. Trump confused,
Trump sweating, Trump lying. But the crowd
mostly loved it. And it is so clear, you know,
we've been wondering for a few months
what direction is this party going to go?
It's abundantly clear this guy controls the
party overall. Right now, not everyone is
on his side. Many individuals don't like
him, especially privately. But officially,
this is clearly still the party of Donald Trump
at this point in time. And just you wait to see
what else we're going to look at today that
this guy was involved in over the weekend.